good morning Nate morning Sherry we'll
see you back downstairs here in just a
second the for you as we move along in
mostly good shape you got to watch for
the lane shifting on the Southbound 15
now from Flamingo down past Tropicana
we'll show you that coming up in a
future report but right now we wanted to
concentrate on the spaghetti Bowl where
the northbounders you're down to just
one lane that repaving project is uh
really backing up now just before the
spaghetti Bowl up towards Lake Mead but
in the meantime there is a crash in this
very same area this is on Washington
underneath the freeway here's a live
picture with emergency crews on scene
once again this is underneath the I-15
on Washington there you can see the
freeway going by so washingtonians as
you're trying to get over towards the
freeway watch out for that Emergency
Equipment that's not completely closed
just a bunch of flashing lights there
we're watching all the freeways for you
and the surface streets too all morning
long